my name is Lee cormers from Canada I
came to Doha Qatar to break the Guinness
World Record of most matches attended in
a single World Cup
[Music]
it's a great challenge I heard about him
earlier in the tournament and I thought
oh local Qatari is trying that that'll
make this more challenging more exciting
I think it's really close race right now
we might even be tied
Guinness is very strict and so I'm a
little bit worried that one of us is
going to have more games but may lose on
the technicality he's got to show your
ticket stub you've got to show how you
purchased your tickets you need two
witness statements from strangers in the
stadiums that you've never met you also
need the video of it so how strict will
Guinness be with video and photography
part in my heart hopes that we tie
[Music]
the biggest challenge this month has
been finding time to sleep the schedule
is very hectic going to two games even
three games in a day some days has been
exhausting but you just need to fight
through those tired moments because it's
the most enjoyable month of my life my
friends and family support me 100 I give
them 47 months of my life and I ask them
for one so this is my month I shut
everything off I leave the country and I
go to the World Cup
I am working as a brand ambassador
trying to bring professional soccer to
my city it's a smaller city of 300 000
Saskatoon Canada we have a Canadian
Premier League that's only four years
old we want to build a stadium at home
and we want to bring a professional team
[Music]
to break it here in Doha Qatar all the
fans are in one place and the beautiful
weather the beautiful stadiums the
infrastructure Qatar will leave a great
legacy for me the people here are so
welcoming they bring you into your home
and they give you supper they give you
food they give you drink there's no
crime here I've never felt safer in my
entire life I could see myself living
here absolutely
[Applause]